a year ago Shin fan became the largest
party in the Northern Ireland assembly
at Stormont for the first time it's now
become the largest party in local
government 2 winning more Council seats
than the Democratic unionist party for
the first time that's a seismic shift in
the politics of Northern Ireland but it
is more a case of shin Fein women than
the dup losing because the unionist
party held its ground in most places it
actually made some gains and can argue
that it has a mandate for continuing its
boycott of power sharing over
post-brexit trailing Arrangements there
is another story from this election too
and that is the continuing revolution in
the Middle Ground the non-aligned
alliance party having cemented its
position as a third force in Northern
Irish Politics as more and more people
choose not to vote along the traditional
unionist and nationalist lines